should we close it out with some punk my
uncle haven't done that in a while let's
ease little punk a so much sheiks hurt
but I don't know what your face face
this is a funky Jerome sent in by
Brandon Springer Rome Rome dude hip you
see he's always sleepy okay he eats
chips and cookies for breakfast and
washes them down with an ice-cold
Mountain Dew his favorite jokes are fart
and poop jokes and he once got hard
watching lady [ __ ] in the woods is it
Stephen Hopkins and outdoorsman uh oh
dude he's out that Nexen be sore in the
morning brother yeah happens on planes a
lot and who's that somebody's uncle yeah
this is uh Brandon's uncle yeah Brandon
your uncle he's gonna hit a few people
there he is
and that's right before he cut his wife
off a killer from from the documentary
stairs have you seen that what do you
guys think when you see a guy like this
and it's what do y'all think about what
do ya see we see an old man with a got
like that ah there he is right there it
is at a Funeral that was before he knows
after I guess also he chopped up his
wife I mean you see a lot of that in
Arizona that much and what does that
mean when you see it man yep give me an
M yeah he was trying to combat the
sleepiness
he just wanted me to say it did they say
what uh what he does for a living yeah
dude he sleeps at work well it's like
his important job look it looks like so
he makes alarm clocks he was testing one
out right there didn't you see him dude
take it and it's behind him on the left
looks like he's dealing some serious
[ __ ] dumb yeah what is he doing he's
Oommen on that left picture please
rocket scientists look at the ship
behind he's a rock scientist that dude
smoking that right he's a rocket time
out solo he cleans up nice now he's got
a scale what else is he doing now what's
in his hand there paintbrush oh he's a
painter
Brendon you don't think made inked dude
this might be the 20th century this is a
trap house he's making drugs bro well
it's a very nice Trap House well look
there's all those markings
the floor what does that mean that's
like a laughs I was like warning it's a
lab he's in a suit do have any
information about this man neck just all
the cookies and Mountain Dew and [ __ ]
here's another video he's 40 yep but it
was he calls that the bouquet of middle
fingers oh well like that
this guy's huge hands - can we look at
his hands there at the very end of that
but yeah look at his dick beaters you
don't see a lot of large handed men like
that anymore big he's very kind of
Paleolithic if you will peel it
it's so cool uncle look I'll say this at
least he walked outside to pass gas a
lot of men won't do that do they do that
in Asian culture chin pass gas yeah yeah
but just quietly yep it's not as big of
a deal this what he what he said was a
I've never heard my mom fart in my own
tire life he's God my mom will let it
rip bombs over Baghdad serious oh my mom
would Dutch oven me when I was a kid oh
yeah you heard your mom fart so I'm
looking for my birthday we got one more
Punk my uncle what is it witness say
Patrick how can you ever get the sound
out of your ears
my mom yes dude my mom one time had to
[ __ ] her pants so bad I was a kid she
parked in emergency lane in the middle
of the mall left me in the car ran in
[ __ ] and then came back and got me
yeah that's being a mom dude but how do
your farts still go on about the light
laughter a super big farting laughs I've
never heard any love them my dad's dead
but I never heard my mom fart my mom
thank god I couldn't handle it and chin
you said in your and your culture it's
not even cool huh you guys want you have
sex loud like this
it's like - yeah it's just like your
penis in Madonna just trying to keep a
secret yeah there's a one big secret
it's a sausage bus the bus does that
mean anything
I mean Dodge Viper yeah I'll try saying
that whiskey Oh David you just text he's
I'm gonna say that all right what do you
got this is uh sent in by Louis from
Illinois this is uncle slick Victor he's
50 years old he likes to watch Japanese
wrestling while hitting his vape he's a
retired stripper but now works in a
warehouse he got married and fall of
last year in Vegas at an Elvis Presley
themed drive-through Chapel and he's
currently just a couple pieces of
paperwork away from getting a divorce
hey men oh yeah he's got a beautiful
fish on him let's see uh it was sort of
videos the fish almost fake oh there's
no video yeah just this guy that's
beautiful out there he's out there by a
lake look at that it's a beautiful fish
yeah it's got a nice sunny on him a
couple Reds maybe carp go through
divorce
oh yes fun but keeping his head up slick
vic they call him up kids catch Slick
Rick at the lake yep he's got a good
smile I like the name vent I likes
anything around my slick is usually a
good name I feel like slick vic prick
slick dick trick no not any word just
any name that rhymes are slick is good
yeah I know I'm just giving a bunch of
names those are names they're slick
brick Rick Rick Lee tick tick I knew it
tick um here's a lifeguard though
there's a mistake don't want that guy
what he I see don't want don't want him
relying on
my life take the lifeguard no absolutely
did my sister when we were kids almost
like drown she was like underwater and
some guy jumped in and saved her and
then came back and saw it's like years
later and was wearing just jean shorts
and no shirt and he came back this guy
sounds like a goddamn hero
and it was looking for a date I don't
know my mom was like what the hell are
you doing here like almost 7:00 p.m.
[Music]